a lot of people don't understand how
debt can put you out of business
if things go wrong imagine being in your
40s
and being wiped out having to go
[Music]
bankrupt
so i want you to react to something sure
i have my entire portfolio
yeah worth a little bit over 10 million
dollars yeah so i want you to go through
one by one just give me your individual
stocks no
this is everything this is real estate
this is every single one of my
investments
got it so i want you to look through
this okay so this is a
piece of property number one purchased
in 2012.
59 000 cash 12 000 reno out of pocket 71
rent 14 000 so this is a good investment
that was unfortunately a cash deal
that was the whole thing was a cash deal
i was all in 71
500 you couldn't get credit for that
right i didn't have a credit card
right so no bank wanted to give a 21
year old
a loan because i had no credit history
okay so right there
um is an important lesson and i tell
every millennial
even though i don't endorse credit cards
it's very hard to advance your credit
rating without
having one so it's good to get a credit
card put maybe a thousand dollar limit
on it
and then start paying off you know use
200 bucks a month
and pay it off every month so i told my
son as soon as you get one trevor
put 50 bucks on the card yep and pay it
off and now he's got a pristine credit
rating and he's only ever put a few
thousand bucks through the car
everybody should understand that there's
no way to game that system you've got to
establish a credit rating
or you can't borrow property two
purchase 2012
cash again seventy two thousand eight
thousand renovation okay so now you're
eighty thousand in the hole rent twelve
hundred a month
net nine hundred after cost right
another two hundred and eighty thousand
dollars because the market is
appreciated yes
you're putting up a lot of your net
worth at that time that was everything
i sold my car at the time so i can go
and buy real estate yeah i get it okay
property three
trip purchase 2012 again same thing 125
000 right
okay that's that's a serious chunk of
[ __ ] i used four years of savings
to buy these i said you're still not
using any leverage
nothing okay well that's remarkable 15
000 rental on top of that
so now you're out of pocket 140 000
that's a little nerve-wracking
red 21.45 per month after cost 1500.
worth 400 000 today so that's a
really significant bump yeah um but you
know you've got to admit you've you've
benefited from the appreciation of this
one asset class real estate as interest
rates
went down correct so there is an
inherent risk of concentration here your
entire net worth is only in real estate
so far
okay that's that's an issue property 4
purchase 2016 780 000 you must have used
that
i did 60 000 rental on top of it out of
pocket 210 000 that's your principal
down payment plus renovation okay that's
good
that's you know also a great investment
but now we've brought leverage into the
portfolio yes
this is the one that you saw this is the
one that i was house hacking on that you
thought was a good idea
yeah 585 loan 620.
wait a second you borrowed more than the
purchase price because they did a cash
out refinance
yeah so what i did is i fixed this place
up i put about
right here 220 thousand dollars total
and renovation
whoa whoa so now it's worth about 1 250
and i did a cash out refinancing
it was a real junker right yeah because
that's a serious amount of change you're
putting in
yeah that one you did a lot of work so
now you're using leverage
and you're spending to invest including
adding more leverage correct
so what i like to start thinking about
in terms of debt
a particular leverage on real estate or
any investment
if the pupil hits the fan and values go
down across any asset class including
real estate you still owe that million
dollars
correct so you got to start being
sensitive to how much debt you want to
bring into your world
a lot of people don't understand how
debt can put you out of business
if things go bad you have to be ready
to pay that million off at any time a
great analogy i met a very very wealthy
uh real estate developer in new york
that came over with nothing from europe
when he was young when he was 18 years
old he's a
multi-billionaire now and each time he
bought a building he did apartments
he would call it either a pasta or a
protein building and i said what does
that mean
he said well i start with my first
building and i would take a lot of debt
down
and i would get the rent roll up so i
was 100 leased out
and i would only eat pasta until
i paid off all the debt i said really he
said yeah because it was just my wife
and i
and we had all this mortgage on that
building and i got i know what happens
during
you know cycles and so once they paid
off that building and now all the cash
flow
was coming out of the building with no
debt on it he'd start to eat steak
that became a protein bar and his whole
life was always making sure
that he had enough buildings with no
debt on it to sustain the downturns
because the new york in those days every
seven years would take a dive of 30
percent
so what he would do is he'd always have
a couple of protein buildings spinning
cash
when the correction hit he'd use that
cash flow to buy new buildings
but he never let he never went bankrupt
because he never extended himself
so far that the protein buildings
couldn't pay off the mortgages
you know of the past the buildings right
you get the energy right
my thought has always been the interest
rate is so low fixed for 30 years cash
flow sustains it
yeah and between the write-offs and
maybe inflation maybe we don't see it
but either way
the worst case for me has always been a
break even on the interest rate that i'm
paying
so okay we go on here so this is
property number six yeah
six this is another duplex everyone is
going up
yes like we're spending more yes we're
putting more debt on
this is 815 000 loan 680
so you put there's a little equity from
day one right right
3.625 very good down payment 115
000 worth 965. okay so that's
good and all of these by the way are
rented under market value
i get it but how long are the are the
leases for one year
and so do you get to bump it up i
don't raise rents believe it or not what
yeah
really really why not um my thought is
if i have a really good tenant who
always pays on time and no issues i
would rather just not raise
the rent and keep them there a long time
and if they do move out then it's kind
of like gravy to me because i'm able to
rent it out for even more to the next
tenant and then tell them
they could stay there as long as they
want at that price yeah and
for me i've had some tenants now for
seven or eight years property seven
purchased 2.1 million that's our number
one right on the hit parade right this
is this year yeah so this is where i am
living now
okay loan this is your primary residence
that's where you got the 2.875
right now at the end of this journey
what is your
total debt nut across all the buildings
about 2.9
okay i'm just saying that would start to
make me nervous
just not because it isn't well invested
that's a big number
like a lot of it can you take the hit if
just look at it that way yeah can you
pay down you know three million bucks
yes as long as you can say yes to that
you can continue to do this but the
minute you get so levered up that you
can't find
15 million dollars i don't have
any debt i don't i've got to a point in
my life where i just
don't like that so i buy things for cash
and i understand
why debt works in this model assuming
the rental market remains buoyant
but there comes a point in your life and
you're still too young i don't want any
obligation to anybody but don't you
think
that's because you already have so much
money
now that for you going and trying to
borrow it three percent to make five
might not be worth your time versus just
the hassle free of
i'm gonna buy it cash don't think about
it well except
because i'm older than you i've seen a
lot of things and i've been through a
lot of down cycles
lots of my friends got wiped out i mean
imagine being in your 40s and being
wiped out having to
go bankrupt like that changes your life
forever because you have that on your
back
i would never want to wish that on
anybody because it is a horrible thing
to happen
and the only reason it happened to them
is they didn't respect debt
you're being disciplined you're buying
assets that have income
they are buying boats and cars and
watches and getting divorced they loved
their lifestyle
they went to zero you have to you have
to respect that and you do
this makes sense to me but again i go
back to that guy in new york
protein building past the building and
the whole idea of respecting how debt
can rip your life apart
that's but so far i don't see any credit
you're not using debt to buy stupid
stuff
right that's basically what's going on
here all right so this
now is uh since your video he's got a
little bit more to go in terms of
diversification he wasn't at 10 because
he didn't diversify enough yeah
well i'm glad to see that because i
never let one asset class ever become
more than 20
of my net worth clearly real estate
still remains more than 20
of your net worth one of your goals
should be over time is to make it
to get such a broad portfolio in your
net worth that
real estate's only 20 so if that asset
class
really has a hard time it can't take you
out of business got it
so let's look at this stock market
investments individual stocks 1.14
million
index funds 7 that's good 772
000. california state free bonds very
good 150
000 silver 12 000 acorns
so using acorn that's good yeah i test
out all the apps so i could give it yeah
that's fine okay
cash uh 320. that's within the stock
market brokerage
it's not all cash just so i i
continually buy into the market the
discipline is every 90 days
to trim back anything over five percent
and put it into something else that you
decided to go into
what happens to portfolios like this
that aren't it's like trimming a hedge
no sector more than twenty percent no
stock more than five
you've got three stocks here over five
you give up some of the upside but when
the correction
hits like a tesla rolls over and goes
down 38 percent
you don't take the full hit because
you've taken profit out on the trimming
i'm worried about taxes yeah because
it's 50
yeah and i'm telling i'm telling you
that's the biggest mistake you can make
in your life is to worry about taxes
the fact that you have to worry about
taxes is a wonderful thing
it means you're making money but to say
oh i don't want to sell
you know stock that's now 11 of my
portfolio because i don't want to take
the tax hit
you will pay a brutal price for that
you'll have a massive correction you
won't have taken any gains
and you will hurt yourself immensely
that's the one thing mistake you're
making here so you've got to do your
work
are you using any margin no that's the
other thing
never use margin in stocks never do that
never never never never people think
margins free
when there's a correction you get
slaughtered right they'll sell you out
in two seconds
cash position 1.8 between cash 1.75
12 months cd 200 000 cash and but you
need this to make down deposit to make
deposits on real estate what is cash for
your total net worth how much cash do
you have
uh versus your entire net worth so cash
would be about
30 that's how much i actually have
more than 30 in cash really yeah yeah
i've had some uh exits in real estate
recently i sold my commercial
real estate and i'm going to wait until
i see what the economy looks like in 36
months to go back in
but as a result i'm sitting on a ton of
cash this is a really exciting one i
don't know if i can mention this in the
video because i haven't announced it yet
but i put
a company called there is startup valued
i've learned from shark tank because
this is a shark tank investment type
thing
you must be ready to absolutely write
that off
because there's a 50 50 chance you will
it'll be a tax loss
very few people can achieve this i
didn't achieve it when i was 30.
that's really really hard to do and the
reason you got there is you're extremely
disciplined
you only deployed capital into
assets that you thought might appreciate
primarily real estate
listen the only negative i could say
about you is that you got too much real
estate but that's how you made your
money in the first place
working on it yeah so what would you
give this one out of 10.
i think you gave me an eight point two
three four as an
operator you know you were an eight but
as a portfolio manager i got to bring
you down to probably a seven maybe a six
and a half
why over concentrated one asset fair
enough so if i just
looked at this without knowing who you
were i'd say this guy is too much real
estate
okay and so um you know but if you
real estate is who you are so i get it
but every all your
all your maneuvering now should be raise
more cash
buy more diversity maybe a little more
conservative you know my portfolio of
i probably have a thousand stocks but
the majority of them
all pay me and they pay me monthly so i
have a really strong cash flow every
month and
my biggest problem is what i do with the
cash and that's how i buy watches here
we go
ichi if you like that video
wait do you see my next one don't forget
to click right over here
and subscribe